let's bring in Gideon Levy he's an
author and columnist with the Israeli
Daily Newspaper haret he joins us live
from Tel Aviv Gideon good to have you
with us so listen I mean the hand
ringing and debate has already started
in Israel over what many see as a a
spectacular intelligence failure that
nobody saw this Hamas operation coming
why do you think Israel was caught out
like
this because Israel is arrogant that's
the real reason I mean we believe that
we have all the devices we spend
billions of dollars in this barrier
which really looks very impressive and
very
threatening and we believe that that's
enough to live in security but when you
are facing a cage an open prison which
is now 17 years locked totally locked or
almost totally locked you can't expect
everyone to sit there still and no fence
can stop it apparently so this
conception that repeats itself again and
again that Israel can do whatever it
wants and we are totally secure failed
again and Gideon we've seen all this
political squabbling in Israel that led
up to the formation of its most extreme
right-wing government how much has this
ongoing political crisis led to what
many see as the degradation of the
Israeli defense Force's Readiness and
its
capabilities I would't exaggerate about
this there are some C there were some
splits definitely what influenced this
crisis is the fact that this government
put all its energy budgets and army to
guard the settlers in the West Bank
totally abandoning the southern front
this is very clear there were hardly
soldiers there because they were all
over occupied with with the the settlers
festivals for soort in the West Bank
guarding them and many times even
witnessing their programs and even
supporting their prgrams so in this way
there is a connection but to think that
the political crisis and the
protest is responsible for the failure
of the intelligence this is one step too
much okay so let's talk about uh those
protests because we've seen months of
anti-government protests on the streets
over judicial reforms put forward by
Netanyahu many reservists though Gideon
say that they wouldn't turn up for Duty
during those protests what happens now
then because in times of War we know
that reservists are the backbone of the
Israeli
military as I always thought the moment
there will be War they will all recruit
and this what happens now we are not
familiar to any cases of refusing until
now everyone who was called came as far
as I know and and and this is very
expected because as as harsh and sharp
and devoted the protest was it was very
clear that when it comes to an attack on
Israel those people including obviously
the pilots who are bombing Gaza now day
and night those will be the first one to
volunteer and to come and to serve what
they think is the interest of the
security of their country um Gideon Levy
just a final thought to you um on the
psyche of Israelis at the moment I mean
this Hamas operation is unprecedented
dozens of Israeli soldiers and civilians
have been taken captive the Palestinians
are saying Israel's pushed us pushed us
too far uh for too long how humiliating
is this uh for Israel and for
Israelis not only about humiliation it's
really about changing your perceptions
about the Palestinians about their
capabilities about their devotion about
Gaza but I think it will take some time
until things will
be adjusted things will
be understood in the in the in the
psycho what you call the psycho of the
Israelis in the consciousness of the
Israelis because it is a shock no doubt
and we will see the outcomes only for
the long run not immediately right now
everyone is shocked and look is looking
for explanations and don't find them but
for the long run I think things will
change this operation in many ways will
be remembered for many many years maybe
as a game changer Gideon Levy really
good to get your thoughts and your
analysis Gideon Levy thank you very much
indeed for talking to aler thank you